Welcome to Austria, babe.
It's cold...
Yeah.
Isn't there summer?
Uhuh.
I can't wait for you to meet the neighbors.
Come on! Let's see with my mum.
Yeah...
- Johannes!
- Mummy!
Hello.
What are you doing? Come on.
I don't know what she said...
Oh my gosh, who is it?!
Oh, yeah, that's Kora, she's the most loving dog ever.
Right?
Do you have treat I can give her?
Nein! /german/
She's on diet.
Oh... okay, why?
She can't walk upstairs.
Yeah.
How old is she?
Eighteen.
- In human years?
- Yes!
I'm sorry.
Welcome.
What would you like to eat?
Oh, uhm... just something small.
Okay.
So...
...enjoy your meal.
Is she gonna eat with us?
No, she doesn't eat.
Oh...
Okay...
Looks good.
Would you like any tea or coffee or dessert...?
Nein! /german/(No!)
I told you she is on diet!
I'm... sorry...
Done!
How can you disrespect my mum like this?
She hasn't eaten in two weeks.
She can't even walk upstairs!
She is eighteen years old.
She is too fat.
I know this is gonna work.
You're gonna have to learn to love me and understand where I'm coming from!
No!
Eh... a little, and...
I don't think it's---
You wear this.
I can't do this...
Amanda!